lobbying is about foresight but  anticipating your opponent's moves she's  your enemy now devising countermeasures  how the hell does she manage that you're  a piece of work Elizabeth I was hired to  win I use whatever resource I have look  the hell does she think she is over five  million of us and we're armed started an  inquisition  they will throw you in jail for  contention conference  winner thoughts one step ahead of the  opposition we have to make it personal  you know the word annihilate  reduced to nothing this is more  important than my career is my body you  crossed the line genius [ __ ] and  completely unbelievable it's about  making sure you surprise them and they  don't surprise you miss Sloan ridded are